okay [ __ ] we're back and I would see
what the [ __ ] would do it now no oh ok
qett gotta go to riverwood i guess [ __ ]
that up this way how [ __ ] far is that
yeah yeah yeah yeah ok not too far so
we're going for Helgen right on when Tom
Martha solitude Dawnstar there's a lot
of [ __ ] place is here rishta alright
we're taking this baby steps okay
[ __ ] baby steps ya no se busca shut
its kind of [ __ ] blocking out this
awesome screams getting dark I mean that
they say you can't take the hate step
off the ketchup Nina oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] or
under attack or under attack okay okay
let's say we're getting mad looks like
we're getting there [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
that I would come out in the air like
what's the deal here now there it is and
I came in through the raw [ __ ] side
let me tell you
okay [ __ ] i guess i made it i guess i
made it okay now the old blacksmith la
race s that's the name ain't every day
we get visitors had fun how do you know
him I'd be glad to help a friend of had
far but you didn't us [ __ ] that explains
what I saw earlier flying down the
valley from the south a trike had Jagan
the first of wine at inr needs to know
there's a dragon on them we need to get
word through your old bald roof in
Whiterun to spend whatever soldiers you
can if you'll do that for me I'll be in
your debt okay [ __ ] I play low game did
I see you talking to spend maybe not me
okay let's go [ __ ] how far they making
me go I'll have to go around i'm out
anyhow trying to get the [ __ ] roof
done
and I will be leveling up this run and
pretty soon and let me tell you
something I'll make it like they used to
I had to be like some crazy [ __ ] but
more one was work was that that game at
[ __ ] death I mean you could buy
slaves when that came this I want and
we're going to attack a deer that's cute
i guess that's cute and a little kid to
like that but the adults not likely far
let me tell you okay my mate I'll yo
great [ __ ] coyote let's try it run to
granny [ __ ] hauntingly
I just still say woof is he [ __ ]
haunting me now he's got he's got he's a
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] what is that each thing
over there
it don't matter if I'd oh well that's
taken care of no thanks to you ha glory
and as companions our glory must and in
order and we show up to solve problems
if the coin is good enough sounds like a
waste of time he would a warrior of true
metal it's quite without then you'll
have stories to tell come up to your
vector no thank you ok I don't need that
shuffle I just looking for an easy life
here I great hockey either displacement
yeah we go here we go okay I'm gone this
way now what the [ __ ]
mm-hmm okay let me tell you something i
turn off that music right away I'm I
even heard the music at Murray six of it
so I'm glad that music soft okay
and I'm here to say the Kang port cities
close with the Dragons about official
business only fine we'll be keeping an
eye on you okay Alice Cairo to Marla's
dope I believe in this breakup so we
must have more swords chat tomorrow that
is no fun getting peploe I you soon I
mean me like no please what do you look
I really don't have an army right of you
know I'll give you 10 seconds tomorrow
even large cattle born until may I don't
know every day but it's how much in this
life yeah why are you such a [ __ ] I
could I was like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah go into dragons rage
[ __ ] what my meaning of it
interruption y'all wildlife is not sure
this [ __ ] length as housing cause my
job is to deal with all dangers that
threaten the y'all or his people so you
have my attention now explain yourself
you know about helgin y'all will want to
speak to you person ok [ __ ] so you were
at Hogan you saw this dragon with your
own eyes yes I by Amir irri left was
right what do you say now preventive
shall we continue to trust in the
strength of our walls against the dragon
my lord we should send troops to
riverwood at once it's in the most
immediate danger if the dragon is
alerting the mountain as a provocation
he'll assume we're preparing to join all
for excite and attack him we should
enough I'll not stand idly by while the
fraggin burns my hold and slaughters
might be a little warm here allez send a
detachment to riverwood at once yes my
young if you'll excuse me I'll return to
my duties that would be best well done
you sought me out on your own initiative
you've done white run a service I won't
forget it you better not better take
this alright thanks for watching
watching